Speaker 1: Let's jump right in, because there's
so much to discuss today, I believe it was
two weeks ago, we did a live stream covering
this horrible mass shooting that took place
in San Jose.
And I was saying and many people in the audience
were saying, as we were watching the press
conferences and the calls for thoughts and
prayers and support of the families and all
of this stuff, are we ever going to do anything
or are we even going to get a proposal to
do something that might actually do something
about what's going on?
And the the biggest problem, arguably in the
United States is gun culture.
And it's the idea of seeing firearms as something
to bolster masculinity, something to make
political points, something to solve interpersonal
problems.
And of course, if we resolved that, there
would be way fewer other problems to figure
out.
Now, that's not the case.
The situation is far more complicated than
that.
And so as a result, we need to do other things.
I'm really glad to say, even though who the
hell knows if this has any shot of becoming
a reality?
About two weeks after that incident in which
the gunman shot nine coworkers at the San
Jose light rail yard, CNN is reporting that
the mayor of San Jose is proposing something
that I've talked about before.
Other gun safety advocates have talked about
before, but has not really been taken very
seriously anywhere, which is a restriction
that would require gun owners in the city
of San Jose to obtain insurance for their
firearm.
If they are a firearm owner, you must get
insurance, sort of like you do with a vehicle,
the vehicle, although it's primarily for transportation,
you can do really irresponsible and dangerous,
dangerous things with the vehicle.
Things can also happen to the vehicle.
And so in most states, you're required to
have insurance on the vehicle, much the same
way you could require gun owners to have insurance
because they are gun owners as well as the
proposal is to pay an annual fee to cover
the cost of gun violence.
And this is one of those things that it you
know, most of the discussion is about let's
ban this type of gun, let's ban that type
of gun.
That's something that we should be looking
into.
Universal background checks.
Absolutely.
But treating firearms the way we treat vehicles,
which includes licensing requirements and
relicensing requirements, as well as mandatory
insurance in both in most states, is actually
a really good idea.
Now, the mayor of San Jose is Sam Licadho
or Licadho.
I'm not sure how it's pronounced.
He unveiled this earlier this week and he
said, quote, If we cannot stop the horrors
of gun violence in our cities and this is
important because just requiring insurance
won't actually stop gun violence.
But he says if we cannot stop the horrors
of gun violence in our cities, at least we're
going to have the public stopped paying for
it.
The Second Amendment protects the right of
Americans to own guns, but does not require
that every other taxpayer pay for that right.
Requiring use gun users to pay fees will help
fund critical emergency medical and police
response and reduce our taxpayers burden.
The way the proposal would work, according
to CNN, is all gun and ammunition purchases
would have to be recorded on video and audio
to discourage straw purchases, where people
who are legally ineligible to buy guns figure
out a way to get a gun through a straw purchaser.
The straw purchasers would be far less willing
to do that if they knew that every transaction
that was legal at some point it's a legal
gun, that they would be less likely to do
that.
Additionally, suicide prevention materials
would be required at point of sale.
This is taking seriously something that many
gun rights advocates point out, which is,
hey, a lot of these deaths are suicide.
OK, yeah.
So we basically have three categories of problems
with gun violence.
We have suicides.
There's no reason not to admit that that's
an issue that is dealt with very differently
than individual handgun homicides.
You will often hear the rights say, you know,
all this focus on AR 15s, most of the deaths
are coming from handguns.
Well, we need an approach for handguns.
And then you have the mass shootings.
These are three different problems, all under
the umbrella of gun violence and gun death.
And we need different approaches for each
of them.
Lakatos or Lakatos proposal also includes
leveraging federal information for early intervention.
This is something that's relevant because
we often will hear and in the case of San
Jose, it was the case that the gunman had
had a previous interaction with law enforcement.
He had been detained by Customs and Border
Protection officers who discovered books on
terrorism and writings that were filled with
hatred towards his workplace.
He ended up shooting up his workplace.
A San Jose police were never notified.
And had no idea that this is someone that
should have been on their radar and there's
a lot of good meat to this proposal now, the
gun rights people, of course, are going to
be against it.
However, not all of them are against it.
And I've said this before, you know, it's
not just Republicans who own the guns.
Yes, it's it's probably more than 50 percent.
But I know many people on the left who also
own guns and every single one of them, particularly
in blue states, is fine with all of this stuff
because they realize that it makes sense for
there to be some hurdles to clear to obtain
firearms.
If you think driving comes with significant
responsibility and licensing makes sense and
insurance makes sense and relicensing and
registration fees and all of these different
filters make sense as as my liberal friends
tend to believe, then it follows that the
same would be a requirement of something like
firearms.
You're not restricting the Second Amendment
by putting these restrictions in place.
You are not limiting one's ability to obtain
a firearm if as long as they are willing to
go through these processes.
So I have no idea if this will go anywhere
in San Jose.
I have no idea if there would be problems
from from higher courts on legal challenge.
This is just step one.
But I've been talking about mandatory gun
insurance for years at this point on this
program, and I'm really happy to see that
this is actually being proposed.
Let me know what else you think.
Oh, and let me mention it.
Speaking of what else, changing culture around
using firearms in the United States, there
are examples of countries with lots of firearms
that don't have our problems.
And the difference is the people, the we have
a problem with the people in this country
seeing firearms as a way to solve problems.
And listen, universal health care, there's
no doubt that if you really want to take seriously,
you know, if you're a gun rights activist
and you want to take even if you're cynical
in your desire to take attention off of mass
shootings and and homicides by putting the
focus on suicides, if you want to be serious
about that, then support universal health
care of some kind, whether it's Medicare for
all, whether it's some kind of provision for
mental health care that is always available
regardless of insurance status.
Because if you really want to deal with suicides
and by the way, mass shootings and individual
handgun homicides, how are we not giving people
full access to mental health care?
So if you want to really put your money where
your mouth is, as someone who claims to if
you're on the right and say the real problem
is suicides, what is your plan for getting
health care to everybody so that everybody
has access to to a therapist and to whatever
it is that they need along that front?
But my question to you is, let me know what
else you believe is the lowest hanging fruit
as far as firearms
are concerned.